[Music]
my ex-husband just won't leave me alone
I've married him and divorced him twice
because he's a cheater you won't cut him
off you need him Like Oxygen cuz you're
scared to death of being alone he's
scared of being alone I'm not why won't
you block him and cut him off and never
talk to him again
[Music]
ever hey this is John this is John with
the Dr John delone
show show about your mental and
emotional health your marriage
relationships of all kinds from in-laws
to kids to schools to work whatever you
got going on in your life shows about
real people going through real
challenging times and my promise is I'll
sit with you and we will figure out what
to do next we get thousands of inquiries
from all over the world and we sift
through them to create a show that's
going to like open your eyes to help you
feel not so alone those of you who are
listening if you want to be a part of
the show give me a buzz at 1844 693 3291
it's 1844 693 3291 or go to John
dooney.com ask ask and just as a
reminder um for those of you who reach
out on Instagram or Facebook whatever
and ask long questions I don't answer
questions on those platforms um just
back and forth texting I found just not
um it just doesn't work um it doesn't
work so if you want to um if you want to
sit with me let's uh give me buzz and
let's join the show um Kelly it's
questions for humans time it's not too
late to get your questions for humans
the Christmas deck where we will save
your Christmas we're going to give yall
something to talk about something to do
y'all can put your screens down stop
talking about politics whatever else is
going on and you can actually learn
about each other we got all kinds of
questions from humans decks we have
dating we have kids we have teens we
have grandparents and kids we have cards
for everyone um go for it Kelly let's do
this is just a Christmas one this is the
Christmas deck yes all right cool all
right so would you rather go carolling
be Carol too or fall face first into a
cactus I would rather like get on a
diving board with no shirt and just
belly flop onto a c c Cactus yeah I'm
definitely um face person to a cactus on
that one no question because hey I I
don't sing so nobody wants to hear me
sing Christmas I heard you sing one time
I literally died and came back alive I
know I understand that um and you were
singing Creed can you take me do we need
to point out to everybody that you and I
are both going to see them this next
summer with a group of people listen
everybody this is the truth um Kelly and
I got Creed tickets yeah we did there's
a whole gang and we're going to the show
Creed toonic Three Doors Down I will
have a Morgan wall and mullet and no
shirt and very very tight black jeans on
and boots and I will rock it on to The
Brak and I will take pictures and make
sure you all see them oh my gosh I just
can see you are just going to wear like
a camo bathing suit top is that all
you're wearing
Kelly it's gonna be incredible it's
gonna be incredible um but the I think
Jen and I had this conversation being
Carol to is so awkward what do you are
you just stand there what do you do and
if you don't want it can you just shut
the door prematurely or you D you got to
be a trooper and just like sit the whole
song but then are you supposed to like
tip them or give them a gift what is I
mean it's weird yeah everyone just
stares and you all like have that weird
exchange and then everybody walks away
yeah it's so great oh yeah I I yeah I'm
not a fan not a fan that's good do
another one that one ends kind of
sadly is Die Hard a Christmas
movie Yes 100% yes no how can you say
that here's why if I don't feel the joy
of Christmas after I end the movie like
if there's not like a Christmas theme
that's prevalent throughout yes it takes
place at a Christmas party whatever it
starts it's a what is more Christmas
about that Bruce Willis no it's not
Christmas M it's 100% a Christmas movie
I feel Christmas joy and la la la no
that's not what I get from it's not
Christmas until Hans grber Falls
backwards out of the window dude I
remember several years ago like I knew
I'd married the right person but when my
wife was like hey it's Christmas we
should watch die hard I remember
thinking dear God I did right I did
right I don't know if you can watch that
movie any time of the year cuz I feel
like you can like you watch let's go
ahead let's go ahead and while we're
here let's go ahead and just do a quick
litmus test of your grasp on reality are
you a dog mom or a pet owner I have a
pet owner all right well you're Tethered
to reality a little bit all right I'll
give you that one are you going to Creed
I I'm not going to Creed because I will
have a newborn baby then oh you're
already that like five months old jeez
it'll be fine it'll be fine this is
called the summer of 99 tour in the
summer of 99 Jenna was a
toddler you and I were functional like
adults so I was a middle schooler you
were you were not in Middle School
so full of it whatever grandma grandma
Kelly all right let's go out to Atlanta
Georgia and talk to the Great and
Powerful Laura what's up Laura hello
hello and I'm too old to go to a GRE you
you listen listen you are not at the
last Turn Style Show I went to um I went
with how old 55 I will be 50 by the time
we go see Creed old uh he's three years
older than me so so 53 he did break a
rib at that show it got pretty while but
no man you can go anything you want
to no I'm more like uh lonel
Richie Barry
Manalo know that's my age group Barry
Manalo and Neil Diamond was the first
concert I ever went to my parents took
me I was that's a great one I was a new
I was an infant
um yeah it's lodged in there the first
show I remember was the oid boys in
Chicago man that was a time ago all
right so what's up how can I help well I
hope that you can help me untangle some
of the mess that I'm in um first of all
my ex-husband we've been divorced three
years um just won't leave me alone
constantly sends me texts about I miss
you um you know I can't be without you
you know texts phone calls emails
whatever now the background is we've
been together since we were seniors in
high school if we had stayed together
last week would have been our 40th
anniversary but I married him and
divorced him twice because he's a
cheater oh so you won't you won't cut
him
off you need him well the problem is I'm
an only
child um my father is 94 years old and
has caregivers and is at his house and
you need him Like Oxygen because you're
scared to death of being
alone I know that I'm scared of being
alone he's scared of being alone I'm not
then why won't you block him and cut him
off and never talk to him again
ever he's he's destroyed your life
multiple times well this is true this is
true but I have three children that are
married one uh one of you're deflecting
why won't you cut him why won't you cut
him off forever and say you've destroyed
my life multiple times by cheating and
cheating and cheating you're not
weaseling your way back in
again explain to him that we will never
be together again yeah but you've told
him that two other
times oh this is
true and probably I may be wrong may be
wrong but in between your divorces y'all
probably had some flings
too you mean with each other or yeah
with each other yeah
yeah yeah so he's just business as usual
yeah that's right he just thinks he's
gonna come right back in anymore he has
every time of course he has you're
exactly right so when when somebody
tells me like hey somebody won't quit
contacting me my first question is well
are you talking to them and they go well
yes are you like responding back yes are
you taking care of them well I mean kind
of yes are you making plans I mean sort
of yes or it's absolutely not it's
harassment and call the police but I'm
guess guessing you're more of the of the
former yeah I am because I'm somebody
that always wants everybody to be happy
I've learned that right and um with my
dad he wanted to you know once this all
happened a couple years ago he said you
know I don't have any family left but
I'm very close to your dad and I'd love
to be able to go see your dad you know
one day a week so he takes some dinner
on
Sundays now you know I asked my dad if
that was okay and at first my dad was
like you know you know and then he said
well okay so it got to be where he's
wiggled his way back in and he has not
yeah he hasn't he has created a
relationship with or continued a
relationship with your dad if I was your
dad okay I'd have my feelings hurt in a
significant way I mean I'm sorry if I
was you and my dad was doing that was
continuing to meet with my ex-wife who
had blown my life up and destroyed my
kids lives twice um I would be hurt by
that but my dad's a grown man he can
make his own choices well my dad has
dementia so you know it's kind like
there you go he hasn't we weasel his way
back in unless he starts messing around
with the will and things like that
that's weaseling back in but you are
allowing him into your
life okay I just don't know why you're
doing that unless you just say hey I
love him he's cheated on me twice we've
been divorced twice but I don't want to
be alone and I do love him and he's hurt
me bad but here we are and you make
peace with that
okay where where's your like where's
your like digestive issues come from
like where does that like what's what's
the what's the
hangup well probably it's because we
have I have three grown children one of
them has grand um grandchildren that uh
were were in contact with him you know
before all this happened they did stuff
together my other two children have had
babies since our divorce and they he has
never met those babies because my
children saw him cheating so you know
that's a whole another different story
they were the ones that saw him the last
time first but you're but you're you're
they're grown adults they get to do that
yeah and I guess it just hurts me
because I think about he doesn't get to
see them it you know I because guess I
care about him I don't love him I still
care about him it's because of choices
made that's right I think you do care
about them and I think you'd probably be
bananas if you didn't have a little bit
of like love in there somewhere I think
the bigger picture is how old are
you 65 65 I think you had a really
really crystal clear picture of what
your life was going to look like at 65
and that guy blew it up now this is
absolutely true and he admits it yeah
you know I'm sorry I did all that well
too bad except not too bad because you
keep going back to him y'all keep y'all
keep going out well I'm not going out
with him yes I mean I don't do St no I
don't I don't do anything no I do not
see him okay I talk to him on the phone
I do not see him how does it I was
getting ready to go on a trip he wanted
to come over here and tell me goodbye I
said what are you talking about and I
just blew up because he's follow he's
just following the tracks y'all have
followed before okay which is y'all got
divorced he cheated on you y'all got
divorced you said I'm I'm a uh I'm not
going to have this in my
house I'm not going to be married to
someone who treats me like this and who
cheats on me and my and the kids and
then it started with well hey we have to
talk because of the kids and then it
started a text message and it started in
a phone call then hey let's just go grab
coffee and then you end up married again
no I do that I know that okay so what's
the benefit of the in
between I don't think there's any
benefit then why don't you block him and
cut him off and say I'm never talking to
you again I'm moving on with my
life okay I'm I'm just I'm not saying
you have to do that I'm just proposing
that why why haven't you done that I
just well okay here's the deal uh he has
no friends that's his problem that's a
choice he's made go what else no money
that's a choice that's a choice he's
made that's a choice he made I I
understand that um he has health
problems and went to the hospital and
you know they said we don't you know
we've got to figure out what this is you
may be having congestive heart failure
what he's got trouble he's got five
stance in his heart so I am the only
one that can help him there's nobody
else that can help my the child that
talks to him doesn't live
here
so you know what do you say I'm sorry
you're sick and you may die I I'll see
you later I mean I I can't in my heart I
can't do that then you have to make
peace with taking his phone calls and
his text
messages and you have to make peace that
maybe you're not his wife maybe you all
don't have romantic interests but now
you're his mother oh that's true I am
his mother you're his
mom so make peace with
that okay he chose on multiple occasions
to not be in relationship with
you he chose to not be in relationship
with his kids by his actions
correct and you have chosen to not let
go
of this fantasy that you've held on to
for almost 40
years and I'm not telling you you have
to let it go but here's what I want I
want you to make peace with it okay if
you're gonna take care of this dead beat
and you're going to take care of him and
pay his bills and make sure he's got
chicken noodle
soup then make peace with that but
that's not what I want to do and if you
want him out of your
life like you called and said he won't
quit calling me well of course not
you're his
mom yeah so if you're not going to take
care of him then cut him off and say I'm
I'm I can't do this this isn't my
responsibility to take care of you call
the Social Security office and I mean I
wish you the
best but you can't heal him you can't
make him be a person of character he's
not going to be you can't make your kids
your kids seem to have more intestinal
fortitude than you
do yes they do
and so I just make peace with
it okay do you see an do you see an
alternative you know what I mean yeah
there isn't I mean yes I I agree I
understand yeah I don't want to be his
mom though I don't want the rest of my
wife being his mom but you've already
decided that's the case you said like I
can't let him just you know bills I need
I need to get some I need to get some
backbone
my problem all along well that's been my
problem all along yeah I remarried him
why did I do that I should have never
done that well it's in hindsight but you
were trying to keep that fantasy
together gotcha and fantasies are
powerful man hope is a powerful thing
it's
incredible
yeah so I'm I'm fascinated what are you
gonna
do
well I don't know I got to think about
it I got to figure out what what I
can let me let me say it this way where
does this end and what I mean by that is
this if he has five stin and he's
entering into congestive heart failure
he doesn't have a long
time and so are you going to write it
out for a couple years with him as he
passes and make sure he doesn't die
alone or are you going to use your
retirement that you had to save on your
own as a single mom cuz he left you a
few times to go run around on you are
you going to save that money and
whatever inheritance your 94y old father
leaves
you to take care of him for the next 15
years and all of his surgeries and all
of his health care and his skilled
nursing and all
that
no that's the question not and so I
think the fair thing to do is to have
that conversation because in his mind
you've always taken care of him for four
40 years more than half is life yes and
so it's fair to say hey this this train
is over I can't in good conscience take
money that go to my grandkids and
support a guy who left me
twice or that's absolutely right or um
I'm GNA take care of this and this and
this and then that's it what am I
supposed to do I don't know I don't know
M you should call the Social Security
office and see where you're
at yeah
yeah
y see what I'm see what I'm
saying
exactly and I don't mean to be cruel to
him but man he's used you for a long
long long time oh yes he has yes he
has yes and your kids your kids could
see it that they're worth more than
being
used and I guess my hope for you Laura
is that
even after all this time you're able to
grieve it would have been your 40th
anniversary how amazing would that have
been and your kids would have been there
and the grandkids would have been there
that's how it was supposed to
be and it's
not and every single person listening to
this call myself included has a picture
of the way things were supposed to be
and they're
not and the quicker we can sit in what
is choose reality we can sit in that and
just exhale and weep
and then our bodies learn that we're in
the driver seat of our own life and we
can then go about making and painting a
new picture all right what's the time
left I'm
65 statistically I've got 10 to 15 years
but potentially I've got 20 years left
my dad's 94 maybe I can do 95 20 or 30
years I'm sorry what do I want to do
with the last
I his mom cool you can do that I'm not
going to get mad at you for it you get
your life you get to choose I'm going to
move in buy my grandkids and just like
be the greatest grandma of all
time you get to pick you get to pick you
get to
pick I do think it's fair to have a hard
conversation whatever that's going to
look like I'm going to continue to take
care of you even though you've hurt me
but here's my boundaries cuz I'm your
mom now or hey this train ends where I'm
done I'm done this money is going to
take care of me me for the rest of my
life and for these babies all right I'm
really anxious to hear how this
conversation goes so give me a holler
back I know you ain't no holler back
girl but give me a holler back and let
us know how that conversation goes I'm
really proud of you I'm really proud of
you we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's delone this time of year
there can be a lot of anxiety and a lot
of drama but it can also be great but
can also be a mix of everything right
especially when it comes to giving gifts
maybe your family makes super thoughtful
handmade things or they expect you to
spend a million dollars or maybe you
just like experiencing time together or
pick up random gift cards last minute
things like gift giving can make us
bananas so no matter how hectic it gets
especially around
giftgiving remember to take care of
yourself whether it's going easier on
yourself during tough moments or having
to say hey we don't have enough money to
buy by all these gifts or treating
yourself to a Day of Silence remember to
give yourself some love this holiday
season and if things get too heavy if
thinking about dealing with your family
and all of the drama gets to be too much
give better help a try better help is
flexible because it's online so it can
fit into your busy holiday schedule just
fill out a short questionnaire to get
match with the licensed therapist and
you can switch therapist at any time for
no extra charge
in this season of Chaos in love in
sadness and all of it rolled up to one
give yourself what you need with better
help visit betterhelp.com dealone today
to get 10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com
delone all right let's go out to Kansas
City home of Patrick momes and talk to
Chris what's up
Chris
hey
Chris hey Dr John what up how we
doing hey I'm doing good thank you for
taking my call today of course man
what's
up hey so um I'm I'm feeling guilty and
scared about sharing text messages with
my brother's ex-wife which ultimately
led to a temporary loss of custody of
his
children I haven't had contact with my
brother in over a year year because of
his behavior mental
state we believe he may be suffering
from addiction to some illegal
substances my family and several members
of my extended family who are involved
in the situation have been scared of
what my brother may do to
us we may be asked to testify in future
Court hearings and I'm struggling with
this because I feel this is the final na
on the relationship between my brother
and the relationship between myself and
my father
I'm sad I feel that the best thing for
my brother's children was to be in a
safe home and my brother hopefully gets
the help he needs I feel like I'm mning
the death of my brother and my father
even though they are still alive there's
a lot of history years that led up to
this latest event just looking for
someone to help me process
this so let me let me wrap my head
around it um you discovered some things
that your brother sent you that made you
really concerned about the welfare of
your nieces and nephews and it was such
that the authorities took the kids away
from
them and because you looked out for the
welfare of those kids your dad's mad at
you your brother W talk to
you and your brother's kind of spiraling
out and this is probably going to end up
in
court yes yeah pretty much kind of a
summary um I haven't had contact with
him um for haven't been in his physical
preference for two years because I
haven't felt py around him do you think
if you if you saw him he would try to
kill you try to fight you like what do
you mean when you you're not safe yeah
ex exactly yeah has he we were
essentially one one Wrong conversation
or one kind a mislook from from him
trying to physically you know harm me
around my children and stuff so do you
have a no contact order with the
police yeah I so I went to file one
uhhuh um during this latest they felt
like they kind of talked me out of it
because I didn't have like text message
proof that he threaten to kill kill or
harm me okay I have text messages he
sent to her mother that said that but
since those weren't directed to
me um I couldn't file my our mother
could which he said was going to kill
your
mom he was going to kill yes uh me who
my
mother he just told your mom I'm going
to kill my
brother essentially yeah um I can get
into more detail
but well let me just come out say do
what go
ahead no go ahead
um well before I say anything and
where's your dad at does he expect you
to protect your brother and he's mad at
you essentially yeah
um he
he's I I don't think I know he's
concerned about my my brother's mental
state and his drug addiction for
whatever reason um he believes
that the children are safer with the
brother and I don't believe that in any
shape or form he's under the impression
that the
ex-wife is having issues but he only
believes that because of what that
brother told him okay so so let me tell
you this as directly as I can okay how
old are
you I'm 35
okay what you did was unequivocally
1,000% the right
thing and I hate it that this is your
brother who's
struggling and you did the right
thing and I hate it that your
father is so wrapped up in his own shame
and his own
guilt that he cares more about his
reputation and he cares more about your
son's reputation and the the lies of
somebody in the throws of mental health
challenges and addiction than he does
his
grandkids I hate that for you you and I
especially hate it for those
kids but somebody had to be the adult
here the responsible mature adult who
said not on my watch and that was
you
and that was
courage because you knew what it would
cost you it would cost you possibly your
safety it would cost you relationship
with your brother with your mom with
your dad and you did that to protect
those kids
and I trust you you sound level-headed
sounds like you know x-wife an ex-wife
probably isn't perfect nobody is but the
kids are safer with her than with their
dad and it sounds like the authorities
thought that as
well so as far as I'm concerned it
sounds like you're a
hero you save some
kids
do you believe me when I say
that I do I do um I'm just kind of
uh been listening to your show now for a
couple of years
and I this this this latest you know
event has kind of just got me SP my
spiraling myself of course you know why
because your dad chose image and being
right over protecting babies and that's
probably not the dad you thought he
was and your mom had an opportunity to
protect you from a brother who said I'm
going to kill my brother and she
didn't and I can't imagine my little
brother's one of the greatest people I
know greatest men I know I can't imagine
looking over my shoulder all the time
that my own flesh and blood in a in in a
season of instability and not being well
would want me
dead
so yeah you're right to be completely un
Unwound sounds terrifying to be honest
with you the whole thing yeah it it's
been extremely terrifying especially for
my for my wife yeah I mean even my kids
can feel it like you say Morris cotton
taught there and Y and they've shown
signs of being
scared in the latest event um I I feel
better it's been several weeks now okay
in a few weeks and I'm feeling better
I'm not I'm sleeping
again um good I'm not as on edge when
I'm out and about around
town but uh there has been you know some
updates and every time there's an
update I kind of feel the tense the the
the scare the T the intensity kind of
creep back in are the updates positive
or the updates
negative uh kind
of kind of more kind of just not a b not
a big change um just updates in the
court okay so here's what I want you to
do a couple of things okay every time
you get one of those calls about the
courtroom your body's put a GPS pin in
this whole situ ation and anytime
somebody brings it up anytime you'll
talk about it it remembers hey we might
get
killed and so it hammers just think of a
hammer on one of those things at a
circus you know when you hit it really
hard and it goes all the way up and it
try to ding the Bell you know what I'm
talking about like just imagine that
because that's what your body's doing
because this isn't like man if somebody
finds out they're going to be really mad
or if somebody finds out I'm going to
get fired somebody has said I'm going to
kill you
and your mom didn't do anything about it
your dad didn't do anything about it the
police haven't done anything about it
yet so your body's
right your body's correct and so when
you feel that when you get a call from
the court hey here's the new date hey
just got court just got bumped again
we're going to ask you to testify will
you review this file and your body goes
hits that thing again I want you to make
a fist and I want you to put it in the
middle of your chest and say thank you
for protecting me I got
it don't try to fight that stuff your
body's trying to take care of you the
more you fight it the louder it's going
to holler at you because it doesn't
think you're getting a
message true and then I think with your
kids I think it's very fair to say uncle
so and so I'll just make up a name Uncle
Billy is really sick and when he gets
sick he can be scary and daddy's been
scared and Daddy's called the right
people and Daddy's doing the next right
thing and your dad will always protect
children even when it's
hard and so what you're doing is you're
letting your kids feel your fear and
feel that tension in your home and
letting them know that the adults in the
room are still driving the
car that's how they'll grow up to be men
of character and women of character and
Men of women of resilience and bravery
and courage like their
dad and here's the hardest thing I'm
going to tell
you your mom and dad have opted out of
relationship with you and I can't think
of a I mean that's just
heartbreaking I hate that for
you
they should be on your side walking arm
in- arm protecting these kids and
they're
not is there any chance your brother
gets the help he
needs I have
hope um I I know it's not going to be a
quick thing
MH I I hope I wake
up 2 years 5 years or down on the road
and he's
better I don't know if we'll ever have a
relationship but if he gets if he gets
sober and he gets the help he needs for
his mental health
disorders I promise you someday he's
going to turn around and say hey you're
the one that kept my kids safe thank
you you're the one that forced me into
court mandated rehab and I finally got
the care I needed thank you for loving
me when nobody else would not not even
Mom and
Dad thank you for seeing through all my
bull crap and how do I know that I've
had these conversations with people out
I care
about they've circled back
around but in the meantime it is lonely
and isolating and in your case
terrifying because he says I'm gonna
kill
you in your heart of hearts do you
really think that's possible that he
would do that is he a violent
guy
um or is he is he a drug addict just
running his
mouth
right before he
started going down the substance abuse
life about three years ago he would kind
of run his enough like this and I and I
did it
feel
we
it's now that he's definitely
unstable um I I have been feeling scared
like I've been you know sleeping with a
firearm next to my bed and things like
that um because he's just
been
extremely kind of violent the way he's
communicated with all of us and and it's
not just within us it's there was a lot
of instances in public where he scared a
lot of people okay just innoc innocent
by standards you know so okay which kind
of led to the
latest that was part of the petition to
the court that
ultimately led to the judge's decision
okay and I will defend
my I I should have prob mentioned this
my mom is involved in this her messages
are also part of the petition so she's
he is doing something she's pretty
distraught in this sure so
sure I mean I can't imagine having to go
to war with my son to protect grandkids
I mean that just sounds so surreal right
that just sounds like not real it's very
very very real and thanks for clarifying
that for your mom I'm glad she's a
person and character too and I know it
feels like there's only so much she can
do what I'll tell you and reiterate um
and again for whatever it's worth for me
because you're the one that's got to
decide I'm not doing holidays this year
I'm staying out of this stuff um and
maybe this is the Year you and your wife
and your kids don't do holidays with
your family you do holidays with her
family yall take yourself to a weekend
getaway somewhere and you'll go
whatever yall just stay out of
town
um but the whole world would look
different if more men and women had
courage like
you who stared down their family systems
who stared down systems they stared down
brothers and sisters mom and dads they
stare
down brothers who are sick brothers who
and sisters who are struggling with
addiction and they said you're not going
to hurt kids on my
watch and it might cost me relationship
with you for the time being it might
cost me a loss of sleep it might cost me
a lot you're not going to hurt kids on
my watch
period I'm proud of you my brother I'm
proud of you um Court can be messy so
call me anytime man and I'd love to have
you back on the show to talk through the
process my hope is your brother gets the
help and care he needs and it might come
in the in the form of a court mandate
the court says you will not see your
kids unless you go get well and man
maybe that will be one tiny little
pinlight through the fog of his
life he can at least follow that
pinlight towards the help and healing
and sobriety and peace that he so
desperately
needs thanks for loving everybody
including your brother including your
brother we'll be right
back hey deloney here look people always
say the holidays are the most wonderful
time of the year and for some of us the
holidays are great but they're Mayhem
for all of us you're probably traveling
all over the place talking to family
members you didn't ask for by the way
shopping GH trying to make it to all the
parties and no one will turn off the
Christmas music but inside the chaos
remember
you still have a choice the choice to
take care of yourself taking care of
yourself begins with a good night sleep
and I believe good sleep starts with an
amazing mattress that's why my family
sleeps on dreamcloud dreamcloud
mattresses have a combination of gel
memory foam and coil technology that
keeps you comfortable all night and
right now dreamcloud is running their
biggest offer ever exclusively for our
listeners 40% off off all mattresses
plus an additional $50 in savings by
using promo code John deloney visit
dreamcloud sleep.com and enter promo
code John deloney to get your new
mattress and the rest your body needs
that's dreamcloud sleep.com with code
John
deloney all right let's go out to
Omaha somewhere in Middle America uh
talk to James what's up James
hey how we doing Dr John we're rocking
it on to the break of dawn what's up
with you not a whole lot I appreciate
you for the opportunity today kind of
speak with you of course man what's up
so kind of a two-part question a little
bit multifaceted but first off um how
would do you suggest people um myself
being the husband validate my wife's
concerns about my mom but also trying to
somewhat back my mom as well
oh man kind of kind of tough basically
you're like Hey how do we create
civilization on
Mars yeah get there right
um you're asking a very impossible task
um what did your mom do that your wife
doesn't like or what is your mom's doing
that your wife doesn't like that you're
that you're quietly secretly thinking I
think my mom's right what is it yep yep
so a couple instances that of happened
in the last probably six months uh the
first one was she you know my family
didn't give my wife like a birthday card
or even a birthday present other than
just like a simple text while you know
her family is like showering me on my
birthday and so she kind of sees like
the comparison situation there okay
that's how it started that's how I
initially felt her feelings for it but
then now it's more of like a I'm a I'm
one of four kids and we're the only ones
that don't have kids in our family or
for our immediate family and everybody
else and my siblings do so she sees the
favoritism of the grandkids and their
families but we kind of get left third
or fourth
fiddle well yeah because they have
grandkids correct and that's that's how
I I I see it that way but how long have
youall been
married uh about a year and a half okay
there we go yeah
um
H so she's not on the phone to defend
herself if she was calling me saying the
same things just from her
perspective I would tell her as quickly
as humanly possible stop the comparison
game and start the communication game
here's what I mean by that hey James my
family goes over the the top with
birthdays mad
house your family um sprinkles some
shredded cheese over nachos for
Thanksgiving I want to have a lot of
love on my
birthday now you have an opportunity to
help meet her
needs yep right the other side of it is
you know your family and after your
birthday when you got showered with the
T of stuff you knew your parents would
never do that correct and so you can
facilitate Mom Dad birthdays are a huge
deal to my
wife send some
stuff send a singing telegram and your
parents be like that's stupid we're not
doing that and say yes you are you're
doing
that and then you can
facilitate that's fair see what I'm
saying yeah absolutely but it all comes
down to as long as your wife is keeping
score she's just going to have a
miserable life does she do this on other
things too like how much your friends
make and who's driving what car and how
big their house is and what their
laundry room looks like uh no not
necessarily like materialistic things
the only that's why it kind of threw me
off with the birthday thing um because
she didn't seem like that would bother
her but I think it was you know she
wants to have this really great
relationship with my mom MH and there's
been a lot of things that have happened
in the last about year with my family
you know her parents my mom's parents
both passed away within 6 months of each
other um and then you know my sister is
going through a husband who's an
alcoholic and then my brother just got a
divorce so it was kind of like
everything unraveled all at once and my
wife is sitting here like well we
haven't done anything wrong why can't we
continue to kind of work on a
relationship since she sees me having a
great relationship with her mom mom that
makes sense or her Dad
too gosh can I be a kind of a prick for
a second yeah
absolutely like what is it about like
watching your mom drown that your wife
sees that and she's like what about
me like that seems super not attuned to
reality yeah and I and I could be just
it could be the way I'm I'm phrasing it
but
I like I have a rule I don't like
talking about people's wives but this is
a
show like I don't know what about that
situation six months where two of your
brothers and two of your mom's kids
that's going through hell she just lost
both of her parents and your wife isn't
there she wants to build a relationship
she's not there on the front porch doing
everything she can to walk alongside
your mom while her whole world falls
apart yeah but instead she's sitting at
home being like why doesn't she call me
me yeah and I and I think too um that
seems super immature man yeah I I think
I think also you know that the extra
part that I haven't quite detailed is
you know like my wife has been the first
person to go help my sister watch the
kids while she's going to visit um her
husband and a rehab facility or were you
know my family me and my wife seem to be
the first people to always
offer up our help and want to be those
people at the Forefront of helping okay
and I feel like she just doesn't know if
it's like my family doesn't know how to
reciprocate that in the sense of like
just you know for example a little
acknowledgement on your birthday more
than just a text but I guess it's kind
of like we keep giving giving giving and
we're obviously doing it for the right
reasons but it just seems like she
doesn't feel that type of love that I
think she wants to H you know in the
source that she wants to have it and you
know like Your Love Languages and such
yeah I mean it it sounds like um okay so
she's not selfish she sounds like she's
very giving and very kind thank you for
claring that clarifying that yeah
um I mean it I would be willing to bet
money this is about
communication yes meaning if she sat
with your mom and said I love you so
much and I want you to be a part of my
birthday party next year
that few things in the world would make
your mom smile more than that yeah and
just teaching somebody else in a
different family system here's how I
like to be
loved because for many a text message is
like a cold drink of water in the desert
oh my gosh they
remembered yep right yep yep and you've
probably had a few birthdays where you
got a text message the next day and
they're like oh sorry we got busy hope
you had a great birthday
then for you let's just help my folks
roll and for your wife that would be the
end of time if her parents forgot right
yeah and I and I think the root of it is
too you know like growing up completely
different lives you know they had her
parents that were um you know when they
had kids they were you know well off had
great jobs and they only had two of them
whereas my family started young they had
four kids so we you know I lived off hme
downs I'm the youngest whereas she's
never had one cuz she has a brother and
just her so right I would be very
careful about doing things early on in a
marriage to try to get somebody in the
new family to like
you because what you end up doing is
treating them like a
401k I'm doing these nice things as an
investment so that you will like me and
I will have this magical fantasy life
that I want to
have yeah versus there's a need I'm
going to show
up yeah and over time if people are ugly
they don't care that I'm there it's not
reciprocated then yeah I'm going to put
my energy somewhere else that's
fine but my guess is with your mom's
life on
fire the lack of attention may
be such a gift to your mom because she
can
yeah yeah and I think too the fact that
we aren't also causing issues is a
relief at the moment too not we causing
issues but you know there's there's
things that have just been imploded on
their on on them and then we're over
here just kind of being successful
couple and just kind of trying to help
out as much as we possibly can but right
and y'all are a year and a half in make
no mistake your tough days are ahead
they'll come yep and it looks like your
mom and dad are the kind of folks who
circle the wagons and take care of their
kids and love their kids and work walk
through hell with them absolutely and
right
now y'all aren't in that y'all aren't in
the storm man yeah
yep so here here's what I would CH
here's my Challenge and it's a tough one
um I don't think you have to Plate mom
plate wife I don't think you have to do
any of that stuff I think it's as clear
as hey honey my mom shows
Love by
being a rid or
die when things get off the rails my mom
will be
there and because there's four kids
they've been running around trying to
figure out what up from down for the
last 25 years um my mom just that's just
not how she does it and she would if she
knew so I'm GNA tell
her hey Mom Dad birthdays are a
humongous deal to my wife and we'd love
to invite you into it next time
yeah and maybe even you take a knee on
this one and say honey I should have
told my mom how big of a deal these kind
of things are how big of a deal
Thanksgiving is how big of a deal
Christmas is here's here's like my house
okay I'll I'll give you a good example
when we first got married um my wife
came over to our house for Easter so
here's like a picture of Easter and I'm
kind of over dramatizing but not
really my dad would get a bag of those
um individual wrapped candy covered
marshmallows they're eggs they're so
good I like to put 14 of them in my
mouth all at once and rub them on my
body okay they're incredible and he
would say everybody turn around and we'd
all turn around he'd stand at the front
yard and throw them into the front
yard just from the front porch and he'd
go look kids Easter money came we'd all
run out and grab them and then Easter
was like over that was it now I did have
some Easter Dr Hunt as a kid I'm overd
dramatizing it right but that's
basically what it was for my wife Easter
families came from States
over yep everybody came out to the dairy
farm was a huge thing so her first
Easter with me and my family was
devastating because Easter was every it
was the most important holiday for her
and her family and for me and my family
it was a it was a way to get
pre-diabetic right and so here's what my
wife did that was so so incredible she
said hey Easter's a humongous deal to me
if this is how y'all celebrate Easter
awesome good for your family I want to
do it celebrate Easter with my family
and I was like great sounds awesome and
so Easter became when we went out to her
family's place in these different
different parts of the country it was
all it but it started with
communication yeah right and then we
figured it out and I could have said I'm
not doing that I like how my family does
it I like us all just sitting on the
couch nobody talking and us just
mainlining sugar and red number
40 but I didn't because I love my wife
right you see what I'm saying so it was
about communication and expectation and
dude it's been magic ever since and so I
think it sounds like that's where you're
at
and I would have no
problem if your wife says gosh I wish
your mom would care more about us I and
and I would have no problem saying it
looks like my mom is up to her eyeballs
in care right
now she's really blessed to have at
least a couple of her kids in her Circle
acting like um adults or being well or
not dealing with some sort of
Crisis and she's really lucky that she's
got people in her family that love each
other and look out for each other like
you guys do we're going to go take care
of the kids we're going to go do X Y and
Z that's awesome it's it's
amazing but I would also steer clear of
do we're not going to do any comparisons
of of course they've got grandkids man
like that's just the way that's going to
be they're going to focus their energy
over
there and I don't have I mean there's no
heartbreak over there y'all can choose
to go over there and be a part of those
conversations or you can sit at home
with your arms folded and be like why
aren't they coming over here well you
don't have any kids you don't any
grandkids and grandkids are fun and cute
and Goofy everybody just sit they're
like they just look at them and they
roll around on the floor or whatever
they do and everyone goes ah and then
they poop and then they eat and they go
to bed repeat right that's just it
that's it and so all I have to say is I
would get my feelings ready that's just
not the stage y are in yet just
not at the end of the day choosing to
look around and be like Why Not Me Why
Not Me Why Not Me is a recipe it's a
choice to be more miserable in the
present I'm going to continue to do the
next right thing the think I think the
thing I think is ethical the thing I
think is aligned with my values I'm not
going to do the comparison stuff and I'm
going to continue to seek joy and Beauty
in my life not seek places where it's
not fair and I know that continual
service and continual avoidance gets
taxing and and tiring after a while then
I get to take my service elsewhere if
that's what I choose to
do but it sounds like just some good
oldfashioned hey we're Newly Weds we're
still figuring this out I'll take it for
the for my family we didn't communicate
we don't do birthdays that well but next
year is going to be off the rails and
it's not cuz we don't love you it's just
how we do it and we're going to do it
differently this time start that
communication now man your marriage is
going to be something very very special
as you
go she's lucky to have you man we'll be
right
back hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to give get rid of your
anxious feelings and be able to better
respond to whatever life throws at you
so you can build a more peaceful
nonanxious life get your copy today at
John
del. all right as we wrap up today's
show a couple things number one we're
talking off air you seriously don't like
circus peanuts it's styrofoam orange
styrofoam those are so
disgusting oh my gosh they
are marshmallows shaped like peanuts
that were that were that were made like
32 years ago so they're kind of too hard
they are there's not that's not
marshmallow
that's like rubber like I don't know if
yall listening or religious people but
circus peanuts are of the Lord that's
all I got to say and especially those
little candy colored those those candy
coated marshmallow
eggs oh my no so good no yes
no no maybe you want to produce another
show with somebody with terrible
taste and hey if you're listening to us
on podcast I got a small little tattoo
of some prayer hands some praying hands
and my daughter saw them and she is
seven and she goes Dad good grief and I
was like what and she goes why did you
get two hands clapping for yourself
tattooed on your body do you and she
goes do you need
[Laughter]
that ah
all right so as we wrap up today's
show
Kelly's literally favorite band of all
time the Great and Powerful Creed and
the song is called hide and Kelly and I
will be shaking it like a salt shaker
whenever they come to
town Creed the song goes like this to
what do I owe this gift my friend my
life my love my soul I've been dancing
with the devil way too long and it's
making me grow
old let's leave oh let's get away get
lost in time where there's no reason
left to hide let's leave let's get away
run in fields of time not th
yme of which there are actual Fields but
fields of time tiim just clocks
everywhere there's no reason left to
hide I don't really know what this song
means who
cares run through fields of time my
friends I love you all
bye